I always try to hold on to like my inner
child because that's the most beautiful
thing you know when you're 30 when
you're 40 and you lost that inner child
I kid you not like if God make the whole
world one day just go black and the only
thing you see is a spotlight of you as a
child you're a cry because you will
realize either how far away you ran from
that innocence or either how close you
still are to it
[Music]
yo what's up guys I'm Thomas dopasiola
whatever you want to call me I'm here
with my co-host Marty O'Neal what's up
this is the dope as usual podcast here
to talk about life problems drugs
accomplishments and everything between
you guys have been bugging every day
since we announced it and this is The
nle Choppa episode thanks for being here
man fans of juice juice before we start
my homies do the chain this is the first
thing I've ever bought in my life I've
never bought a couple days ago yeah and
as jewelry for me is very like I'll
break that yeah you know what I mean
like especially you you're you're
energetic you don't never hit you in the
teeth yeah for sure
that's one of the things
um this is me meditating right here when
did you start meditating uh over like
three years ago about three years ago
have you attended some astral projection
or anything I actually do yeah you know
a few times
um I just rejected one time and it was
like as soon as I did it I like messed
it up and like I came back because like
it's kind of like a sleeping State
really but um I woke up if that makes
sense could you see your body when
you're looking down
um I did I did it like two or three
times once off of like seven eight grams
of shrooms oh for real and I was just
looking at my body and like you said I
messed it up the first night I messed up
went oh yeah I'm tripping yeah yeah it
fell back into my bed like where I was
it's kind of like uh someone's dragging
like a cartoon huh like Space Jam when
he gets taken the Space Jam world that's
how I felt yeah man all right so damn
astral projection just through clean
meditation like oh yeah do a clean
meditation just off you know just
breathing and um
I've done any other things with shrooms
as well to where I went places but the
first time it was just you know just me
how long did that take like oh it was
like
a few weeks a few weeks in you know I I
was meditating hard like one week when I
first learned how to so I kind of like
became a professional I guess just of me
learning myself and you know so
something that everybody here is like
yeah it's probably something I should be
doing but nobody really knows how to
like effectively meditate in a way that
it's like you know first thing we bring
up an interview down here it's a
superpower yeah yeah yeah yeah the
superpower man you almost feel like damn
as happy let's go do this kind of like
X-Men right now you know what I'm saying
you don't have time for like visualizing
like things you want to have yeah like
visualizing um prayer
gratefulness and you know things I want
to see come to reality so manifestation
so yeah that's what we preach on this
show man we talk about it all the time
that's literally what our audience is
all about is you know set a goal work
toward it because you can always see it
in five years I'm gonna look back yeah
yeah so your plans are good yeah The
Five-Year Plan I just I just started
doing a man in a it works but for you
five year plan you were 15 years old
you're young as hell bro and and that's
crazy I had a five year plan at 15 yeah
and I did it I did it I did it faster I
did it um a lot of things I um created a
plan for me and I did it on the next
year so like I was 15 and I was rapping
and I ended up like blowing up the next
year I started at 14 but I put like you
know a goal or like a milestone goal for
me and I ended up blowing the next year
and a lot of things coming and I did a
lot I did a lot of things that um I
wanted to do in less than five like a
year damn dude because I remember 15 or
20 I was just on packs you know so it's
it's different when you're talking
because we have a lot of people on the
show sometimes they're 25 Doctor Drew 60
years old so it's a different
perspective like he knows so much more
than I do because he's obviously with a
the older I get the more I realize these
old fools got some knowledge yeah we're
saying the idea that you've accomplished
this much and you're like correct me if
I'm wrong not old enough to even buy a
beer yet oh yeah if it's not old enough
to even perform at a lot of clubs they
probably won't even let you in yet don't
even think about that crazy they let me
in here
you know I can't just walk in the line
and probably go in the club unless it's
all face but yeah performance wise yeah
it'd be crazy so so you saying before we
started you're doing intermediate
fasting you don't touch till 12. so I'm
not no no so I'm doing Ramadan I I mean
I said no but I mean done so I'm gonna
sign up I'm not consuming anything when
it comes down you know I break fast with
like water or juice and I just eat fruit
I'm also taking it another
level yeah another level because I'm
only eating fruit so so he's like
outside of the Ramadan do you do this
often yeah yeah I always fast so oh all
right because like I was telling Marty
like I started to eat me like six seven
years ago when vegan like six but I've
been eating that fast food vegan but you
know what I'm talking about and like
four weeks ago I took the food allergy
test they told me you're allergic to
everything yeah all gluten all soy so I
just been eating raw and and bro yeah I
feel better but I'm bored it does get
boring but you know what it creates
when you get bored with it you either
got two options you know stay
disciplined keep going keep being bored
or take a moderational break you know um
relapse have a relapse you know just try
whatever but you know once you do it
make sure that it's only for that one
day and then you build up another day
you know another another goal of how
long you got to go again if that makes
sense yeah like I'm about streaks I'm on
like day 38 yeah I'm like you know what
let's go a year let's see how we yeah oh
that's just how my brain gamified almost
my whole life yeah as soon as you chose
veganism well you say like seven years
ago oh yeah I'll never go back yeah it's
just like it's over from that point I
just like animals too much man I felt
like the first time I was like this is a
body part yeah
so how long have you not eating meat for
um it's been three years around three
years as well three and a half damn you
weren't even 18 thinking about this
already right I was like 17. it's the
heat of the pandemic so it was like 2020
like
20 20 kind of started around that time
what does Dr sebi mean to you all right
here mobile that's the reason why I
stopped eating me oh for real I was
smoking a joint my fiancee passed towels
watched YouTube I was like who's this
man that was it four in the morning I
watched like eight or nine in the
morning and I never even meet again bro
I fool just I don't know what it is but
the way that man spoke that energy oh
man I feel like there's no
artificialness there's nothing there but
like
knowledge if you want it you can take it
yeah yeah and then I saw this little
jump drop into his knees like this was
85 years old that's him
I was telling people that I was like I
don't think I understand how um how
crazy it is to be of that age and be
able to drop down at your knees like I
can't even do that I wouldn't do that
man you ever see the videos of him
smoking joints yeah yeah this man so
much dude he had a lot of lives nah it's
just like oh okay he was 80 something
years old smoking I mean a monster joint
would you like I don't know where I was
giving them [__] yeah I mean that's the
epitome of like yeah I made it as an old
man is there anybody else that you like
listen to or look up to in that regard
as far as like Health goes
um
hmm
I gotta go with um new you know you got
to go with nip because he installed
something in me um
he influenced me a lot just an aspect of
first and foremost ownership and also
the things that he was standing on and
standing about because I didn't know Dr
savy until I heard him new when I heard
him but he brought it to him yeah so
that's when I kind of Discovery so you
know and I noticed like looking at your
credits like on your new project it's
your record label yeah Junction with
yuck like that yeah that's what the
message he was putting out there as soon
as you feel like you like learn from
that when you started your label
deliberately yeah man it's like pretty
much just
initially it wasn't because I knew it
was more so like just a patience and
wanting to always feel free and always
um
I feel boxed in a chapter having to do
things that you know I didn't want to do
you know and just putting it all the way
in my home court so within that process
I stayed patient I got a label I got a
label deal and um it's to the point
where they gave me my masses I own my
masses I got my own label I have
creative control I can wake up and say I
want a job tomorrow you know what I'm
saying so it's like things of that
nature is important especially when
you're a creative person so the most
important yeah you know full creative
control Pinnacle of the music aspects or
the business aspect of music because
then you can do whatever you want with
your music forever basically yeah
guys it's tax season here in the US you
might have a little bit of expendable
income coming in you might want to
invest in yourself it's manscapes go to
manscape.com Yola for 20 off and free
shipping manscape has the full package
for everyone out there it's the
performance package 4.0 invest in
yourself good hygiene all right whether
they say hot girl summer don't be sweaty
ball summer guys we already know the
lawnmower 4.0 is the star of the show
high tech Advanced Skin safe technology
Precision for your pubes it's got LED
lights you can navigate it's got
waterproof rear wettest situations this
package also includes a brand new weed
whacker 2.0 and the nose hair trimmer
skin safe technology new motor new blade
every single thing to make sure you
don't slice your balls open guys
manscape we're also coming with the crop
preserver the anti-chafing ball
deodorant and moisturizer and the crop
reviver spray on toner for those balls
manscape now has beard products beard
hedger Pro kit has everything you could
possibly need to make sure you look like
hook nine plus products come in this
April's testicular cancer awareness this
month manscape's partnered with the
testicular cancer society to help raise
awareness and spread early detection for
men's testicular cancer manscape.com
forward slash Yolo's 20 off of your
entire order plus free shipping thank
you for supporting the brands that
support us back to the episode
that's a question that first video which
of your homie shot that which one of
your homies shot that video for you the
first thing you ever do because if
you're young you know you're like yo I
got the song bring your camera up fool
let's all start getting hyped up how did
that go down because that is the epitome
of like yo this is independent music
right here you guys are just going nuts
I think it was in the front of is it
your house are you talking about like my
very first video yeah or Shadow flow or
the very first one I want to say it was
the very first one I watched so much
what happened was um it was this lady
that I knew that was shooting videos
around the city at the time and um she
basically sent me a free video because I
kind of already had a buzz around the
city with my name and I feel I told I
was like yo it'll be a good look for
both of us you know so I like 15 16 yeah
15. mixtapes or just off of you being
you oh it's just me being me you know
and um people knew me musically as well
and um I shot it in my in my homie
housing
yeah I always like to see that first
video because you can always go back
like this is the house we were talking
about in that song yeah
well it seems like your whole like the
whole aesthetic here music is based
around like your neighborhood I mean you
got Cottonwood one Cottonwood two right
songs coming out soon right part two
yeah April 14th yeah so I mean that's
what we're here to talk about you
obviously just you're supposed to come
on but you're like hold on I gotta go to
UK I know Lil Wayne come back we'll do
the interview how was that flight man it
was be cool it was cool you get to one
of those lay down things it's like you
could be time traveling I sleep the
whole like I just said a whole different
world that's amazing yeah I can't my
first time ever slept was on the way to
New York and I won't like time travel I
woke up like yeah right
I ain't flying bro watch Final
Destination too much as a kid it's a
real issue yeah so uh ain't gonna answer
um
because I you know you're doing your
thing it could be you at night when
you're turning your lights off and your
bathroom it's just you you know what I
mean it's just you and you look like
I got a little weight on the damn song
you have to do you have to be a little
bit like man we just heard it on the
radio last night and I just I went crazy
because I've never had a I've never had
a song Hit Radio that fast like never
you know it's new it I think they said
there's no it's number one right now
rhythmic radio
I always did and um he got 42 ads the
first week and um
where the first five days it got 42 ads
they said usually the norm is like 15.
so there's throwing and you say ads like
they mean 42 radio stations added it to
like rotation oh damn so this summer
what you're saying it's gonna be a song
of Summer
it's already yeah like 42 ads is crazy
that's it that doesn't happen it's just
been what like five days yeah so it's
crazy and that and then you've you've
done all this it's not like your uh my
first songs were these huge giant artist
I'm popping it was more like I built it
and then you got probably the greatest
rapper of all time on yourself yeah
that's a trip I was listening all the
way here and uh it had that like
almost like Southern juvenile energy at
the beginning like I felt like oh damn
felt like Amish to Back That Ass Up am I
wrong okay all right so I felt the two
it was stunning Like My Daddy on the
first half of the hook and I was like
what we doing making money yeah the
second half I did back that ass up then
in the one you know versus I gotta like
Wayne reference I just wanted it to feel
like the hot boys yeah you're like
paying homage to his hole oh dang you
know yeah I feel like that's why when he
heard it he was like yeah I got a step
he took it to the ethers with it you
know he went all the way out of space it
was a beautiful moment it still is
that's just recent this week too and I
always feel like uh I mean for you too
and it doesn't matter what age you are
in a week you're still gonna have that
feeling like in the year you're still
gonna be like damn remember last year
yeah yeah that's out of that's the
that's the vibe I get also question I
know it's not even in our notes you're
on a different generation what the hell
were you watching as a kid what were you
watching was it cartoon it was a nickel
I wanna I wanna know what um
yeah what were you watching because I
was watching SpongeBob I ain't gonna lie
I thought was wrong about I got so many
SpongeBob toys bro I feel like it helped
with my personality too like being
growing up in Memphis I feel like
they helped me to have a joking
personality but still had to be a tough
one in the grilling one but you know
um so SpongeBob of course like family
games you know all that type stuff but
SpongeBob is my thing if you wanted me
to stop doing anything
bro I I said it recently but it's like
that show's been out for like 23 24
years old I think I could watch it
forever but I didn't like that Patrick
spin-off [__] though I didn't see that I
don't know about that but a new
SpongeBob band that you need Squidward
being a dick next door you need all this
money hungry Mr Crab [__] for that show
bro I like talking about when they just
had just Patrick yeah I don't really
feel that yeah I'm good I didn't know
that happened I want to take a look at
Patrick life more here yeah it's like yo
you can do that with Oracle you can't do
that Patrick yeah okay let's say
um
damn sorry I forgot I was just about to
ask you so okay so you said SpongeBob
was your [__] as a kid so
have you seen I mean I grew up I won't
we'll keep it clean SpongeBob movie yeah
that's how I saw it yeah all right the
first one I watched this [__] like 100
because my little cousins and it was the
second one too I forgot I forgot it was
the second one I forgot how I went
though yeah I don't remember that at all
right
so all right so that's what you were
watching growing up now something that's
kind of interesting is like Memphis or
Memphis is a little city right yeah but
it's got legendary music history out of
it we're talking Three Six Mafia we got
I mean there's like I've Googled it
famous rappers from Memphis it's a long
list you're right it's on top of that
too yeah that was from Mississippi but
you know man
so have you had any like uh growing up
like are you like not like working with
artists and stuff that you're like
listening to locally or showing you love
and stuff man black boy JB he was like
he was like with me the person I was
always um reaching out to before I blew
up and um dming them like yo we gotta
get something going and like he's always
when he was in his highs he was always
entertaining me you know what I'm saying
and it meant a lot because he was the
first reachable artist I could reach
that was established you know when I was
15 14 and they gave encouraging words so
black boy he always like I always brag
on block
um I work with Three Six Mafia I've
worked with um with Gotti I work with
bag you know all of these people I was
listening to before I blew up so you
know it's been crazy it's a real ass
feeling yeah it's crazy
and who'd you grow up listening to like
if it was top three albums to kind of
Define I wasn't never like an album
person I feel like this more so I think
oh yeah
Pandora's you can skip so much you can't
just CD and go yeah I'll listen to the
whole CD but with me I could give like a
top three artists like you know I was
listening to first and foremost a lot of
pop and um a lot of Lil Wayne and um
a lot of UGK because of my pops on me so
I was about that yesterday question you
said uh I know it's crazy but like yo
what what helped you SpongeBob help me
break my [__] because you because you
could be goofy and still hold your own
yeah so the the person that I feel that
I kind of I saw that and then when I saw
you just dancing your ass off but your
lyrics like this Fool's like my little
brother he always said like everybody's
like you're so goofy but yeah but the
girls are laughing at me right they want
me back to come hang out right my
brother smashed it
but uh but I was saying you know who Mac
Dre is that I think is like the perfect
mix of like you're goofy dancing at some
funny ass fool also be safe
peace don't Rob him that's how I feel I
was a you like The Jacka The Jacka Jacka
from the bay
you're welcome put me on put on the
jacket put on Street out more tear gas I
was bumping it the whole way here just
randomly selling packs and Santa Cruz
just like brought me back those specific
albums you know what I'm saying so I
just want to see because I know you're
you're younger but if you really know
who Mac Dre is I feel like you're gonna
like the jacket the jacket it's like a
real hard gangster it might have been
even like a thousand is 16.
17. I was thinking about this morning
randomly and I think that's why I put
the album on actually
um okay sorry we're getting off topic
your new album Cottonwood too coming out
uh feature can you can you talk about
who's on it besides
so besides Lil Wayne
I get job one I want to drop one or two
I'm gonna do two so I got the big gold
Lil Wayne I gotta go with um I got Polo
G as well
and um
since my songs let me out it's going
crazy I'm gonna give a freaky song I got
one with uh Kevin Gates oh damn y'all
can imagine how this one Kevin Gates
like how you did the roll out of lack
do XYZ we're gonna drop a couple songs
early and then you make like three four
songs if you go on there they're
available now yeah he made me do that
before it's teasers yeah that's a nice
way to like kind of get the fans excited
and give them a little bit like uh so
what is it 22 tracks yeah
it's gonna be basically 18 new trash
dropping yeah
album bro I got like I got over
um different anything different anything
versatile I was really looking for you
know
I tried to type into every move tap into
every genre every feeling so you know I
got songs that's similar to do it again
which give you the dance feel you know I
got love songs for the women I got
ratchet songs for the women you know I
got on the turn up for the guys you know
when us riding slows for the guys so you
know all of those things I feel plays a
partner making a you know diverse album
because you know it might be someone
this might be their favorite song but
you know for another person this might
be their favorite songs and it's two
different you know Vibes so you know
yeah it's just trying to appeal to
everyone I kind of feel like uh it's
almost like directing a movie yeah she's
trying to like what emotion is going to
come out when I bump this like you said
practice songs for the women and love
songs for the women like there's two
those are two different statements yeah
you know what I'm saying like
like you said it's the vibe what are you
feeling this is the summer song yeah and
this is when you're chilling with your
homies and it's the garage smoking weed
song yeah I I I'm not keeping it you
know to me you know what it is for me so
your version on the way you can put it
yeah it's it's a like I said it's like
directing a movie like what are you
trying to draw from the audience and
bring it out yeah you know what I'm
saying yeah you just added a bunch of
tour dates too oh yeah for sure so it's
like moving San Diego but then you're in
Prague and you're back Casey you're all
over the place what's up online
traveling so much man it's a stressful
one but um it's a blessing so it's a
stressful blessing you know what I'm
saying this is what we this is what I
prayed for when I was still what I
prayed for when I was um
stable when I wasn't moving you know
what I'm saying when God isolates you
sometimes so you got nothing to do but
to talk to them man no everything is
moving it's hard to complain it's hard
but you know yeah
you know that's the same I think it's
the mentality you got to keep yeah
because when you were 14 on probably
what Vine going down one day I'm gonna
blow up on this [__] and now you're 20
going [__] I'm tired [__] it's a fourth
flight this week it's
you gotta like it's like that POV you're
looking down like I really did that [__]
yeah man it's crazy you can whatever you
want on your life you can do it so now
like as I'm manifesting more work I'm
manifesting more peace because I know
it'll come manifesting more vacation
days because I know it'll come because
the same way to um hard work is coming
or how our work came
um it's the same way you can just ask
for peace and mental mental breaks and
all of those things so it's all about
what you ask for and God's gonna give I
love that I never asked for a break
that's [__] smart bro damn I'll be
tired of [__] like yeah I'll get it in a
couple of minutes a couple months two
years goes by so I feel that I haven't
got I haven't found that balance yet
dude yeah man but I feel like it's been
over four years where I've been busting
ass so it's time to you know read what
I've been sowing and um I feel like
we're doing that I can afford days to
where I'm like I need to block out this
schedule for this because I went hard
four years you know I ain't really had
no vacation I can count on one hand
really
probably four fingers how many vacations
I had in four years it's crazy and you
weren't unplugged you're sitting there
still answering [__] hitting people back
maybe posting songs yeah oh yeah you can
never turn it off but don't yeah don't
turn it off because once you do you
might get comfortable yeah you can't do
that you can't do it man I did it
remember fiance had jaw surgery I was
like yo don't bug me nobody bugged me I
had to do a smoke weed for three weeks
and after I'm like oh I really don't
want to get up yeah and I've never
slowed down in my life I'll never do
that [__] again I felt like the crap to
try to get up you know I'm just like
damn five hours of filming [__] you know
so yeah I feel like even though you I
mean you're 20 you got your energy you
can go hard for four years you're 30 in
your head yeah you're saying you haven't
been maturing you're taking more flights
than the average American in their life
in one month it's stressful man even
though you're chilling what do you want
to drink I'll take that and fall asleep
it's still stressful as hell and then
being a different time zone and maybe
different languages and [__] must be a
trip so about the UK you wake up what's
the first thing you notice different as
hell
man
air like not even when I woke up it's
like when I landed like the air is just
this is dinner like nothing thick it
don't feel are you polluted or something
yeah don't feel too polluted it just
feels like
I don't know it's like I feel that if
that makes sense yeah you've been to
Portland Oregon before
um
that's what it feels like here it's like
I can breathe deep
yeah yeah because out here in California
I'm from the uh Central California and
it's like the number one poorest place
for air like because all the
agricultural sprays so yeah I moved to
LA my lungs got better which is crazy
because the smog out here but California
is the best place ever if you don't want
to breathe and [__] yeah it's pretty fun
telling you
has it been weird like I was just
wondering like thinking your kid in high
school know everybody super locally
famous and then you start Crossing into
these upper levels of Fame like did you
learn any difficult lessons with people
that you know in your inner circle
having to pick who am I gonna still like
have a relationship with and who do I
have to like kind of Disconnect from is
that a huge issue man it was it wasn't
an issue it was more so it was a it was
a headache over time but
for my greater good because I'm a quick
learner you know I love to learn I love
to hit the waters and test them
um
but yeah man I'm also learned that you
can't take everybody with you you know
you can't take the whole hood you know
what I'm saying you got to pick the
solid ones and know who those people are
and um test them
um battle test them and see you know
what I'm saying you can't just think
everybody's straight everybody is to be
trusted because that it gets you burned
and it'll get you set up
that whole situation was just like such
a grim reality like really just got to
be on point at all times like if you're
gonna be out there and just make sure
you stay safe yeah man no so for sure
for sure I mean yeah
that's something that you learned mad
young I'm just learning that yeah bro I
I I know you've been in a situation like
yo whatever you need let's do it it's
been six months before where you at like
I've been offering and like let's get it
going and then you start to realize like
you can't you can't help everybody
around and then you kind of feel like am
I being selfish as [__] no you got to be
it's crazy when I was young
good I had to I was at the Master P
basketball camp and um it was mass Peter
and it was Romeo Miller there and um
well this is one guy that was speaking
and he said if you want to be successful
if you want to get what you got want to
get out of life you got to be selfish
and
I feel like the way when I first heard
it I was like well that's kind of
inconsiderate I was like I was like you
don't know what he's talking about but
when I grew
I feel like God make people say certain
things to where he's always on the back
of your mind and then once you grow to
understand it for your own understanding
how it's applying your life it'll make
sense and I was like yo I'm not selfish
I'm always consider it of others but I'm
always putting myself first in any
instant and I feel like that's what he
was pretty much saying he just didn't
say it right yeah but
um I understood what he meant and now
like I make sure that
four points or anything I'm pulling it
yourself and even pointing to myself can
benefit the next person 100 so it's hard
though so you you got that down it's
crazy it's like I'm like 10 to 12 years
older than you I know like I keep
forgetting he's twang I keep forgetting
because like no because like I'm trying
to get to that stage of be selfish and
selfless at the same time it's a hard
balance bro because you know you wanna I
need to get their hers in the house and
you get them a house and you stop
worrying but then again it's like
bro I gotta I gotta build a family one
day I gotta make sure I'm good because
if I'm good you guys are good yeah so
it's just kind of it's a thin line I'm
trying to tiptoe over here yeah yeah for
sure yeah but balancement is always good
you know you don't always have to be
all the way here and all the way there
it's just finding that balance and
however you do so like my thing is I say
yes a lot so I try to find time to say
no like I say yes a lot so I try to at
least say no And when I say no it's not
because oh I I've been saying yes too
much it's more so like
okay I really don't like that I really
don't want to do that
um I usually say yes so let me say no
and you know that's when you protect
yourself from something so 100 yeah
especially if someone traveling the
world doing your thing in the spotlight
you kind of have to build that because
like I said you're 30 in your head so I
understand where you're going with this
um
there's a question I wanted to ask I
just this is completely spaced on it
right now go ahead what was your like
creative process as far as like writing
and being in the studio like how long
did it take or the sessions like what
was your routine for this album it was
more so like listening to the beat and
whatever the beat say to me like just
jot it down you know I know freestyle so
I'm more so pen and paper and like I'm
really old school with it sometimes I
type songs on my phone but you know it's
more so just like being creative
I'm not saying something I ain't see it
before and um just being in the moment
you know trying to make the best verses
I can and um make catchy hooks you know
yeah some songs don't even need to lose
so it's just like attacking each song
with how they should be specializing
like on your Wikipedia it's like singles
yeah yeah
that's the energy too man like you said
it's you can be goofy you can still make
fools be stoked hard ass music uh
question I know it's way back to what
we're talking about
YouTube cleanses and all that how do you
I I've been going to the doctor I've
been trying to get this stomach thing on
what do you suggest that I should be
doing I know I've read I'm reading a
burdock root I've been reading a lot of
stuff about all the I got a bunch of
teas and stuff I just don't know like I
need to clean my in my stomach and my
body out I've been doing this clam being
raw and doing this like
I need to be this full size in a year
like I'm tired you know I'm gonna be
honest if you want a raw diet as far as
whether your route die because okay so
the only thing that's not raw is when I
cook the bean like Black beans okay
stuff like that you know what I'm saying
um
this is like all no gluten no soy just
no potatoes no starch it sucks dude yeah
how many times do you consume
just bound like once a day now it should
be more I'm doing all right I mean how
many foods you could swim in as well
because Bruce is what creates bowel
movement a lot about well uh
that much dead I guess I would say like
I chop them I don't bite that [__] no
more I've been a peach once there was a
spider in there I traumatized the [__]
out of me never again yes never again
it's crazy
like honestly
if you if you if you build build your um
eating habits around fruit so if fruit
is the primary like the base and then
you build it around like yo I'm gonna do
a salad but I'm gonna make sure my fruit
intake is large because you got to think
about it if we're consuming a lot of
vegetables and stuff vegetables don't
really like uh create bowel movement
like how fruit would you know vegetables
is pretty much like that they're really
oxygen so they dehydrate in your bowel
in your stomach and that's how they
break down by dehydrating it so
sometimes if you're consuming a lot of
um vegetables instead of fruit
it would dehydrate the body a little bit
so fruit actually is what brings
hydration because it contains water it's
perfect melons and stuff yeah so like if
you if you if you primarily consume
fruits and then make
the vegetables and like the secondary
the secondary uh it creates more bowel
movement and you pushing out weight and
then yeah sense of that just start to
add implementing herbs like simple herbs
you can do like seam all so I guess I
got a [__] was expensive yeah yeah man I
got a little bundle of it that's what I
asked because I know uh your second
channel was awakened Chopper right
that's what you're talking about like I
could still be goofy and have fun like
that [__] that's what most artists are
lacking yeah like Drop it here listen to
me like me and I'll see you in a month
and I feel like that's why it's kind of
like poisoning the community because you
got like people looking at the
entertainment aspect and thinking it's
real life but we're really supposed to
live life and have fun like it'd be the
most Savages guys but you never see them
crack a smile but off camera they
smiling they joking they laughing they
doing those things and um it's not shown
I feel like more kids need to see that
you know what I'm saying you know
because I I know a year you're young
still but think about your homies at 14.
impressionable as hell my homies yeah
watch something now you're doing it like
Bart Simpson I used to I almost broke my
damn arm because I was like I can jump
that [__] too so it's impressionable so
when people see like oh he's he's nice
too he's chill maybe something very
considerate it's uh a side you don't see
fools are usually Lokes on hard as hell
what like
little kids are wearing this through
Tick Tock and just oh online like it's
even gets down you know and then you're
just kind of normalizing like oh this is
cool like I make my own products and I'm
thinking about my skin and my health
yeah that's normal this is cool you know
you're not you're not hearing that in
the hip-hop anywhere else like I said
make it popular talk [__] to your homies
I literally no stop littering I try to
say on Twitter but talk [__] to your
friends [__] kids dude but it's just
a it's another layer man you're adding
and people get to see the behind the
scenes and not just when you go on
interviews or yeah the most you see out
of full crack of smiles a breakfast club
when someone says something like bro
just laugh yeah okay yeah be you yeah
just be yourself be pretend your mom's
in the room and your grandma's in the
room you're nice and you're happy and
you're chill I always try to hold on to
like my inner child you know always
because that's the most beautiful thing
you know when you when you when you when
you dirty when you're 40
and you lost it in a child I kid you not
like if God make the whole world one day
just go black and the only thing you see
is a spotlight of you as a child you
will cry because you will realize either
how far away you ran from that innocence
or either how close you still are to it
so who you actually are yeah that's
that's who you are that's you and your
purest form you know so I feel like I I
saw on this lecture of um Dick Gregory
and it was so dope he said um he said
the only goal in life is
to come back home to come back God is
pure as how you came so he said I said
yo this deep you know that man needed
his own show yeah it would have lasted
two seconds of people would have got
pissed I already know he's he's
the more deep version I think of like a
comedian like he's like the deeper damn
that [__] was real he says real far
behind it yeah but also like yeah you're
kind of funny yeah yeah dick Craig is
funny as hell
um
so yeah keep that connection
what do your parents think about this
about what about you doing your [__] oh
[__] they look yeah
pops over there oh no [__] you're dead
that's nice man you must be stoked as
hell
manager and I got my deuce here at home
I don't know why she didn't come I think
she's tired huh
oh your hair done women women I think
we've had a couple of your homeboys on
the show who did uh DJ ghost first
interview oh yeah g on here you went
viral on the show yeah we got that high
as hell are we any music with either of
them in the future
um in the works
ddg yeah that was it nine lives coming
up we just did yeah yeah we kind of did
something like six eight months ago it's
about that yeah so yeah and it goes um
goes we we don't do nothing musically
but he's pretty much like a homie yeah
he's chill as hell Honestly though yeah
we did his first interview he came
through and uh
it's boxed it honestly he's chill as
hell he's got the perfect recipe like
you always just be myself on camera pay
me YouTube oh I love it dude he's got
the perfect recipe I just talked [__]
about things I like review the music
video like he's got the formula he's the
the talk show and the MTV for the
generation of now I feel yeah because
we'll listen they will listen and watch
yeah for sure it's good [__] man and I
feel like you you branching out going
there is just they're your homies too
but it's more of like
it's like a DOT connection almost like
oh you guys are all chill you guys are
all chill oh he's goofy he's nice and
it's chilly music fans
oh yeah it's like uh when Family Guy and
Simpsons did that episode everybody lost
a damn mind that's exactly how I feel
when this happens yeah you know what I'm
saying yeah I was wondering we just have
Matt Barnes in here he was making his
predictions I know you're into
basketball I saw you on Amazon Prime and
all that yeah what's your thoughts on
the finals this year
I got a Legos I feel like everybody's
trying to kind of Mount a little bit but
I got him
I got him taken I said your team in
general now I'm I'm actually a Laker fan
of the simple fact of me being a Kobe
like die hard Kobe like I'm Kobe to the
Bone so I've always kind of held on to
the Lakers but I'm a Memphis fan as well
you know I don't want to be the person
that had two teams but you could do that
[__] yeah I root for the Grizzlies and
the Lakers and it's crazy they actually
like Rivals right now so but I feel torn
I really want the Grizzlies to take it
all though like that would be beautiful
for the City of Memphis
um I kid you not
if the Grizzlies win ever win the
championship
Memphis is going to be in [__] um
the city's gonna be torn down bro yeah
they're gonna go [__] ape [__] that's
the only team there right
and you say it's a small City yeah
they're gonna go nuts yeah they're gonna
go nuts it's gonna be breaking it's
gonna be cars set on fire it's gonna be
crazy
it's gonna be a riot of happiness
I've never been to the South I went to
Texas once and
you ever been to Texas yeah there's
nobody outside I went to Dallas there
was nobody [__]
out I'll walk the streets I was smoking
joints for real yeah and nobody's I
think it might just be too [__] hot
or they know like yeah
but no I haven't really traveled so uh
the south is somewhere I've never been I
got a lot of family uh from the East
Coast but I never met those fools so I
never travel I don't try to wear weeds
not legal so I feel like yo that's that
fool search is bus search is vanley and
I'm done so the Texas don't even bring
weed what did you think about Hustle and
Flow did they like to pick Memphis the
right way hell yeah it was perfect it's
a Memphis class I actually just met with
the old man that directed it
um I'm currently trying to do a movie
with him no [__] yeah so all right is
this movie something that you thought of
or is it something brought to you like I
could play that no I was like 100 like I
thought of it's like I gotta real life
yeah did you write out your dialogue and
all that already I already got a lot of
Acts going with it writing it out oh
damn you're really on this yeah for sure
how long did it take you to like write
it to write the whole thing after you
got the idea in phase one so it was like
it took me like a month to write what
I've already written I haven't written
no scripts or anything but it's more so
like uh how I want it to be shaped
pretty much a foundation yeah I try to
pitch my thing a long time ago but it
was you remember Grandma's Boy you ever
seen it uh did you watch uh
they're talking about video games and
like they they're video game testers or
whatever
um uh you see Waterboy yeah you know the
quarterback Dante Peter Dante he's only
I'm saying in the movies I pitched him
that's my homie and I was trying to
pitch a show to this dude and we got it
we got the script written no she wasn't
funny at all what I wrote was funny and
then the script lady was I just stopped
like yo that's just not funny I wonder
how many shows just die how many
people's dream to die because this fool
couldn't imagine 0.9 of them that's some
[__] dude okay yeah and I know you're
mad busy is there anything you watch
um
hmm
sports TV show anything
not SpongeBob I just saw Creed me too
this was good it was a good ass movie I
like uh I won't spoil it but that boxing
scene where everything kind of faded
yeah
cinematic movie you know the boxing the
boxing shots was crazy so good right it
was chiseled like and then when they got
the close on the belts my bro
that's what it looked like huh or NFL
when they do that 8K [__] and everybody
looks fake when they get on the players
yeah that's just too much it's a crazy
career yeah I just watched it yeah I
just watched Cree I'm burnt I didn't
know they're about Rocky
I put on Creed one I go Apollo Creed is
this what I'm saying I felt so dumb and
then Rocky walked in like oh it's Apollo
Creed's kid and I watched them all and
watched Creed Three okay it's a good
movie man it's very good good move we
had a so you just watched all over I
just watched them all last week which
one is your favorite one three yeah I
gotta say crushed it three I feel like
the plot two is in three two like when
they showed at um
the demand that the man that hit dude in
the hand I already knew it was gonna
happen I'm like crazy uh I think we
won't spoil it I I agree with the bad
guy yeah they're like a hundred percent
you got played you gotta understand you
gotta understand you got played you
gotta understand you know 18 years what
it was yeah I'm not trying to spoil it
but yo I left that movie going the bad
guy is the good guy this is [__] I
felt I felt real bad for that man but
we'll leave it at that go watch that
damn movie it's good um you watch
snowfall at all I don't know ah damn I'm
stuck comes out tomorrow last one I
think you should watch it man it's about
uh we had Rick you know the real Rick
Ross you know who that is yeah we had
him on here and that shows essentially
they stole his likeness again bro it's
crazy he never got paid for any of these
movies or any of these stuff about he
never got a dollar we interviewed him
about it how he got himself out of a
life sentence and [__]
that fool needs to be
and there needs to be a blockbuster hit
about this man because to putting that
much work in I mean the biggest culture
on Earth life sentence then getting out
where's that movie at me we need that so
it will come he better get paid for it
bro because I feel like that's
attractive foreign
that's what me and him been doing for 10
years so we met and started this man and
we're doing the same thing just using
the comedy I was in the wheeze world and
kind of missed you know you do comedy
well I work with a lot of the comedians
as a graphic designer videographer
advertising web all that type of stuff
yeah so he did and then this got big so
he kind of just dropped everybody and
now it's just us yeah that's perfect man
I mean I know wait did you used to smoke
weed yeah I feel like you did right yeah
when did you stop
um three years ago okay
so you're you're never going back I feel
oh I'm not talking about weed like your
your life is just on this discipline
yeah for sure
all the way
Autumn good man good [__] I just got to
keep going keep involved I never felt
like like yo this I know age don't
matter but it's like bro I've had 10
more years to learn and think of my life
and I feel like you just streamlined a
lot of it like no you got a jump start
off yeah you got it you got it going
this is sick like I said we talked to
the fools in their 60s and sometimes
it's like five you're playing like I
don't know I'll get something done this
was kind of done all right so compared
to what you wrote out when you were 15
you said XYZ I'm gonna set out what's
that next five years look like from here
now that you've accomplished all this
now I gotta tell you Brian I know
and when I say this
I'm not Money Motivated you know I don't
wake up and say I want money I don't
even carry cash I don't care about it
but I do know the significance of
um the level that money holds and I know
like how you can help people with it you
know I feel like if it wasn't money
um
it'll be a system of gold silver and
bronze if it wasn't gold silver bronze
you'll have a system of barter Goods so
who has the most wheat yeah so it'll
always be a level of yeah you really
thought that would have a financial but
my goal is to be a billionaire before
I'm 30 and um
is extremely possible because very
possible I just gotta stay disciplined
and um I want to do it though so I can
help shape the world and a better place
you know I don't want to be the
billionaire that's dirtying up the world
I want to be the one that's like okay
let's
um create meditation centers let's
create um
better prisons you know or something
like that not to like build prisons but
how do we change the prisons how do we
reform prisons
um
things that are nature like vegan vegan
food um anything that revolves around my
lifestyle yeah so and your lifestyle is
all positive it's positivity so
spreading is not a bad thing yeah I feel
like it's what I say season one like by
the time I'm 40 I just want to be
billionaire I know it'll happen and I
always think like what's the thing
that's gonna get me there I don't know
what it is but then I'll take back on
this moment I don't know like I said
it's kind of like
foreshadowing to yourself yeah you know
trying to build it like you know when
you're a kid in school like damn 30
minutes left [__] look away 20 minutes
oh hell yeah that's how I feel with life
like damn's two years of work down good
[__] so like with you I feel completely
possible one the only thing I have
gives because if we do more I own like
six businesses make something tangible
for somebody yeah yeah that's the
biggest thing I feel like 50 Cent
crushing what vibing water has nothing
to do with me perfect
and I feel like people did something
tangible now they can all right yeah I
can support this by the way it's not
just because I like his music and then
some people like who is that I don't
even know his music I love this product
and that's when you are Walmart and
that's when you get into Target and my
homie just got to walmart.com one of his
products like it's a trip the things you
can do to become a millionaire like that
yeah for sure it's a trip and I'm making
the right decisions the right people
around you to guide you to help me so
that and I feel like being a piece of
[__] being a little greedy even if you
do it behind closed doors it will come
back no matter what someone's watching
your ass it's almost gonna hit the
button on you so yeah something's gonna
happen dude like that's what I pick up
trash when no one's looking like yeah I
dropped I'll pick it up talk shots
get it get it make it a trend all right
um but I know you you're on a schedule
you got to get you out of here
Cottonwood two right before April 14th 4
14 man and then ain't gonna answer ain't
gonna answer out right now going crazy
summer
number one record so damn we appreciate
you coming on I appreciate it thank you
and work everybody finds you just nle
Chopper right usually type of music on
Instagram and Ellie chapter one on
Twitter and any type of music on Tick
Tock and Nelly type of music on Snapchat
whatever you know so yeah that's it man
well good luck congratulations on
everything man we really appreciate you
being here I know the fans are choose
bro they've been bugging me for all the
tour dates we got San Diego coming right
a bunch of cities so Ticketmaster for
everything just be just um go to the
Instagram page and it'll be updated on
everything you post a lot bro yeah you
post a lot and
by call to actions like yo this is my
[__] it's white but nobody does this
[__] everybody's too [__] cool only
poses like clothes pictures and chains
like you're too [__] cool for your
own good I don't think you get it yet
yeah so good shift good for you I got I
like this Instagram is cool yeah
appreciate you thank you for being here
thank you thank you nice to meet you
nice to meet you guys this has been the
dope as usual podcast Mario Emily Chapa
have a dope ass day
hey it's good to start the morning the
highest [__] I like this damn
okay thanks for watching the podcast if
you thought this was dope you'll like
this episode too and don't forget the
best way to support the show tell a
homie